cette année pour remplir sa hotte le
père noël va devoir parcourir plusieurs
kilomètres
premier arrêt saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
c'est ici qu est implanté son taux ce
faire cette société existe depuis plus
de 30 ans elle imagine dans ses locaux
des jeux sensoriels inspiré de la
méthode montessori ou encore des kits de
loisirs créatifs c'est pas uniquement
les petits jeux sur lequel on joue
pendant dix minutes c'est réellement des
choses on va avoir un apprentissage on
va avoir et on est vraiment sur le
premier le principe de faire les choses
soi-même de réaliser des choses on est
dans un monde où on va de plus en plus
vite c'est aussi des jeux qui vont
prendre leur temps avec ses boîtes en
carton 100% recyclable sentosphère mise
aussi sur l'écologie une valeur partagée
par une autre société
direction versailles où s'est installée
depuis peu le siège social de nature et
découvertes
depuis sa création en 1990 l'enseigne
s'est spécialisé dans les produits de
bien-être des produits également liés à
la biodiversité
parmi les cadeaux plébiscités cette
année ce nichoirs pour oiseaux ou encore
ces jouets pour les tout petits
et nous avons aussi cette année leur
lancement de notre gamme pour les 0 à 3
ans qui s'appelle gallopin des bois qui
une gamme devait jouer très vertueuse
parce que nous n'utilisons que du coton
bio pour les enfants nous utilisons du
bois fsc de forêts gérées durablement et
enfin dieu la peinture sans solvant pour
les plus grands nature et découvertes
mise notamment sur une valeur sûre la
lecture un mes coups de coeur en livrent
en ce moment c'est le livre vivre avec
la terre de charles hervé gouyer de la
ferme du bec hellouin qui nous apprend
les grands principes de la permaculture
et qui est un très très beau cadeau à
offrir
[Musique]
depuis 2015 la nostalgie à son royaume à
houilles
c'est ici qui est installée la société
naftal gift points comme ce site
internet propose des articles sur le
thème de la nostalgie des jouets des
bonbons qui nous font voyager dans le
temps
3000 produits sont référencés on voit
souvent dans les tendances les gens qui
créent leur coffret avec plein de petits
bonbons et justement il faut mettre un
jeu d'eau agnès et vont faire leur petit
coffret pour que les imagine les
personnes retombe en enfance
des coffrets nostalgique proposé entre
30 et 40 euros